habt ihr euch erschrocken ja mögt ihr
das Nein mag ich jetzt erschrocken zu
werden er ist recht nicht und was machen
wir heute wir lassen uns erschrecken
be home wir sind allein zu
hausean SPI
wirpan
re ich hasse
Horrorspiele
ich will das
[Musik]
nicht es war eine warme Sommernacht
meine Eltern waren auf Geschäftsreise
und nicht zu Hause ich hatte das ganze
Haus für mich
[Musik]
allein
ich habe kein Bock m was klingelt hier
was fliegt Daum was S das toess oder was
Harry Potter mein Gott okay ich bin in
Zimmer sit aus wie 1814 wir stehen auf
und befinden uns in unserem Kinderzimmer
anscheinend wenn hier jetzt links um die
Ecke direkt was kommt ne ich schwöre
euch ich berende direkt dieses Video
direkt
ich dachte da steht jemand aber es ist
noch
mein wenn ich auf den Stuhl schaue guck
mal wer da es ist ein
Auto ich hasse Horrorspiele mich regt so
auf ich habe noch Hausaufgaben heute
Nacht aber ich bin zu hungrig das heißt
wir stehen auf und gehen wahrscheinlich
in die Küche es ist alles eine Frage des
Settings ne ich meine wenn ich theor
[Musik]
habe PR to
Crouch warum soll ich du brauchst dir
nicht zu essen bestellen ich habe dir
schon heute morgen Lasagne gemacht schau
mal im Kühlschrank nach okay
Mama
ich schaue im Kühlschrank nach da ist
auch eine Tür ist mir aber
egal hier vorne ist der
Kühlschrank ich gehe um
die warum soll ich schon wieder
crouchen okay dann
Crouch dannou
ganzsam oh mein Gott oh mein Gott oh
mein Gott
warum alleine auf nehmen die Lasagne
food was cold okay packen in Ofen
[Musik]
jaer startet gerade eine Rakete auf dem
Dach ich steiger mich da vielleicht auch
so ein bisschen immer rein ne in
so horrorspi
aber ich will da bei Fernsehen gucken
willst du mich
verarschen ist wahrscheinlich das
Wohnzimmer jedes Horrorspiel ist halt
auch gleich aufgebaut bzw jedes Haus in
Amerika okay setzen uns hin
äh muss ich den Fernseher einschalten G2
throw ach du kack das wollen wir noch
essen okay okay okay ich Set mich ich
schau schon
[Musik]
F ist deine verdammte Lasagne du kleiner
Hoh müssen wir hier irgendwie mit der
lasagnegen ach so
ach wir können
einer die Treppe hochgegangen scheiß
drauf dum Wicher Mason Oliver was willst
du
jetzt wir müssen uns morgen treffen Bro
bei mir kam gerade was rein du musst
morgen zu Jessica kommen ah okay chillig
also Mason Oliver wollte anscheinend
vorbeikommen hat mir jetzt ein Korb
gegeben dich
Bruder ich will nicht nach oben gehen
sorry alles gut Bro ich brauche dich
nicht in meinem Leben Oliver ich habe
mein eigenes Leben und ich schaue nur in
die Kamera weil ich Angst habe auf
meinen Screen zu schauen und ich nicht
möchte dass hier irgendetwas passiert da
sich meine Frau hier allerdings in dem
Spiel ein bisschen unwohl fühlt und
schlafen gehen möchte gehen wir jetzt
schlafen drück ich auf das Bett ich weiß
es nicht ich
drücke always before
bed mich nicht
umdrehen ich will das
nicht ich sehe es nur im
Augenwinkel Tür ist
geschlossen ich gehe ins
Bett was steht da ich will es nicht
lesen ich es ist wieder weg was stand da
i remember I had homork to do before ich
muss noch Hausaufgaben
machen wo ma ich die Hausaufgaben
wahrscheinlich im Garten bei kompletter
Dunkelheit wie
geht's nicht
[Musik]
gut warumelt die
Uhr okay ist
keiner machen wir unsere
Hausaufgaben could Focus because of
TV
ich habe den Fernseher angelassen wisst
ihr wie spät es ist wo ich das Video das
spiele gerade
Spiel
[Musik]
1:9 B du was scheiß drauf scheiß drauf
ich bin ein erwachsener Mann ich gehe
jetzt nach unten und mache den Fernseher
aus kann ja nicht so schlimm sein als ob
hier jemand drin ist vielleicht habe ich
mich einfach nur vertan schaut mal Licht
ist an alles ist super es läuft super
klasse Musik im Hintergrund ich habe
euch gerade mal im Schnitt hier den Ton
vom Spiel ausgemacht denn ich persönlich
ich werde gerade ziemlich therapiert da
stand gerade irgendwas ich weiß
allerdings nicht was von daher Lauf wir
jetzt zum Fernseher sind wir beim
Fernseher nee sind wir noch nicht sind
wir jetzt
[Musik]
so
aus
warum gehst Du schon langsam die Treppen
hoch wo bin
ich okay hier ist GUB ich
Eingang allesy alles gut alles gut alles
gut alles gut wir sind drin wir sind
drin Freunde wir sind in unserem Zimmer
hier sind wir sicher wir machen die Tür
zu perf
schlafenchlafen
du musst noch
[Musik]
immer mach deine
Hausaufgaben ich wundere mich dass wir
noch leben und dass wir noch keinen
kranken
Jumps 1238 Uhr wenn die Uhrzeit so genau
daingeschrieben wird dann passiert
irgendwas wirwen uns ins
Bettchen
bleib nicht zu lange wach ich möchte
nicht schon wieder von Paula hören paul
ist anscheinend die Nachbarin und sieht
wenn wir wach
sind gehen schlafen wir gehen schlafen
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott wir haben es
boah ey for real Freunde
[Musik]
es
kann ich
mehr ich kann das nicht
[Musik]
mehr
ek die Kühlschrank Wasser da re zum
Trinken und und geh zum
Wegwerfen ab nach
oben wir haben
geschlafen wir haben getrunken wir haben
unsere Hausaufgaben
gemacht und jetzt können wir vielleicht
endlich mal schlafen gehen
monieur ich spiel das ganze Spiel gerade
nur noch mit dem linken
Augenwinkel wir machen die Tür
zu und wir gehen
schlafen meine Mutter hat mir Bild
geschickt Miles wer ist das an der Tür
bist du zu
Hause da steht einer an der
[Musik]
Tür also wir haben eine Person im Haus
und noch einen an der Tür meine Mama hat
mir das Bild geschickt kann ich an ich
kann Antworten J alles gut Bro komm
scheiß drauf diger wir schauen einfach
mal es kam einfach ein Sound bevor ich
die Tür geöffnet
habe sche scheiß drauf wir sind strong
wir sind laserlaca also nicht wir
sondern ich und ich bin eine ziemlich
Pussi
aber Mama vier Nachrichten Paul send me
sie achee ach du scheie geh nicht an die
Tür egal was schließt jeden Raum ab und
versteckt euch in eurem
Zimmer was soll ich tun ich bin
unten
dazu und wir verstecken
[Musik]
uns
was soll ich
tun jetzt
K
pa at the door das ist niemals
Paul
niemals du hast mir vorhin geschrieben
ich soll nicht die Tür aufmachen egal
was passiert ich hö auf dich ich bin
unter mein Bett unter mein Bett bin ich
sicher kan noch 10 Jahre lang
weiterklingen ich stell
auf der Nachbarn ist auch Licht
an Pala ist doch meine
Nachbarin wenn bei ihr lich dann ist es
sie ja ob wie sie zu
Hause ich weiß nicht ob ich aufmachen
soll könen wir irgendwie aus dem Fenster
schauen ob sie das wirklich
[Musik]
ist
ja komm komm wir nicht besser zu tun h
auf
runterer
B
sie war nicht und das Spiel
hat Spiel hat sich
beendet ach so falls ihr mehr Horror
Games wollt es wird nicht passieren